in the last video we looked at a
function and tried to draw its
derivative now in this video we're going
to look at a function and try to draw
its anti-derivative
anti-derivative which sounds like a very
fancy word but it's just saying
the anti-derivative of a function is a
function whose derivative is that
function so for example
if we have f of x and let's say that the
antiderivative
anti-derivative
of
antiderivative
of f of x
is
capital f of x and this is tends to be
the notation when you're talking about
an antiderivative this just means this
literally just means that the derivative
that the derivative of capital f of x
which is equal to could say capital f
prime of x is equal to
f of x
so we're going to try to do here is we
have our f of x and we're going to try
to think about what's a possible
function that this could be the
derivative of and you're going to study
this in much more depth when you when
you start looking at integral calculus
but there's actually many possible
functions that this could be the
derivative of and our goal in this video
is just to draw a reasonable possibility
so let's think about it a little bit so
let's over here on the top draw y
is equal to capital f of x so what we're
going to try to draw is a function where
its derivative could look like this so
we're essentially doing is we are
when we go from what we draw up here to
this we're taking the derivative so
let's think about what this function
could look like
so when we look at derivative it says
over this interval over this first
interval right over here let me do this
in
purple it says over this interval from x
is equal to 0 all the way to whatever
value of x
this right over here
it says that the slope is a constant
positive one so let me draw a line with
a slope of a constant positive one and i
could shift that line up and down once
again there's many possible
anti-derivatives i will just pick a
reasonable one so i could have a line
that looks something like this
i could have a line that looks something
like this
i want to draw a slope of
a slope of positive one as best as i can
so let's say it looks
something
like this and i could make the function
defined here or undefined here the
derivative is undefined at this point i
can make the function defined or
undefined as i as i see fit this will
probably be a point of discontinuity on
the original function it doesn't have to
be but i'm just trying to draw a
possible function so let's actually just
let's just say it actually is defined at
that point right over there but since
this is going to be discontinuous the
derivative is going to be undefined at
that point so that's that first interval
now let's look at the second interval
the second interval from where that
first interval ended all the way
to
right over here the derivative is a
constant negative 2. so that means over
here i'm going to have a line of
constant negative slope or constant
negative 2 slope so it's going to be
twice as steep as this one right over
here so i actually could just draw it i
could make it a continuous function i
could just make a negative two slope
just like this and it looks like this
interval is about half as long as this
interval so it maybe gets to the exact
same point so it could look
it could look something let me draw it
let me draw it a little bit neater it
could look something like it could look
something like this
could look something like this the slope
this slope right over here
slope right over here is equal to one we
see that right over there the derivative
and then the slope right over here
the slope right over here is equal to
negative two we see that in the
derivative
now things get interesting once again i
could have shifted this blue line up and
down i did not have to construct a
continuous function like this but i'm
doing it just for fun there's many
possible anti-derivatives of this
function
now what's going on over the next
interval
what is going on over this next interval
and i'll
do it in orange the slope starts off at
a very high value or it starts it starts
off at positive two then it keeps
decreasing and it gets to zero right
over here the slope gets to 0
right over there and then it starts
becoming more and more and more and more
negative so i'll just try to make this a
continuous function just for fun once
again it does not have to be so over
here the slope is very positive it's a
positive 2. so our slope is going to be
like
this is negative 2 so it's going to be a
positive 2
and then it gets more and more and more
negative up to this or more it becomes
less and less and less positive i should
say even here the slope is positive and
it gets to 0 right over there so maybe
it gets to zero it gets to zero maybe
right over here and so what we have we
could have some type of a parabola
so a downward facing parabola so notice
the slope is a very positive value it's
a positive 2 right over here then it
becomes
less and less and less and less positive
all the way to 0 right over there and
then the slope starts turning negative
and so
our function could look something like
that over the interval let me draw a
little bit
let me draw it a little bit neater
this is this is symmetric however
positive our slope was here it's equally
negative here so our curve should
probably be symmetric as well
so let me draw it let me draw it
like this over that interval it could
look like that
and then finally
over this last interval
this last interval or as i guess we
could say it keeps going our slope is
zero our slope is zero right over here
and once again i don't have to draw a
continuous function but when the slope
is zero that just means that just means
that i have a line with slope zero i
have a horizontal line and i could draw
that horizontal line
up here in which case i'd have to say
it's it's discontinuous or
or
i could draw that horizontal line right
over here and try to make my
anti-derivative a continuous function so
once again i could have shifted any of
these segments up or down and gotten the
exact same derivative but then i would
not have gotten a continuous function
like this
but we have been able to construct a
possible antiderivative for f x and just
a reminder that's just saying
this f of x is the
the anti-derivative is a function that f
x could be the derivative of